よっ！
俺の名前は
エダワード・エルリック
エ：皆は俺のことを
エ：エダと呼ぶよ
エ：そしてこいつが俺の相棒
僕はタナフォンス・エルリック
タ：僕のことを皆は
タ：タナと呼ぶよ
エ：はは･･･
エ：最高の弟だろ？(少々滑舌が悪いですね）
エ：というわけで今日は
エ：俺たち"錬金術師"で
エ：とある実験をしたいと思ってるんだ
エ：アル
エ：あ違った、タナ
エ：見せてやりな
エ：というわけで
エ：やる･･･もうウゼえ髪の毛
エ：人が結構いそうな場所に来てるんですけども
（急に敬語）
エ：「モノの価値」って知ってるか？
エ：モノには価値がある
エ：同じ価値のモノを交換すること
エ：「等価交換」という
エ：そうだろ？弟
タ：そうだね、兄さん！
エ：はっは！
エ：モノの価値は人によって違う
エ：俺たちにとっちゃこの
エ：小さな賢者の石
エ：全然価値のないただの石ころだが
エ：人によってはこれが
エ：すごい価値のあるモノに感じてしまうことがある
エ：そうだろ？弟よ
タ：そうだね、兄さん！
エ：はっは！
エ：こんなキャラだったっけｗ
タ・ｗｗｗ
エ：じゃあ多分今日は
エ：等価交換と言いつつも実際やってる事は
エ：物々交換
エ：だが等価交換と言うことによってちょっとこう･･･
エ：かっこよさが出て･･･
エ：やりたくなっちゃう･･･かもしれない
エ：そうだろ！弟よ！
タ：そうだねｗ兄さん！
エ：ハハハ↑ッハ↑ッハ↓！
タ：アハハハ
エ：というわけで物々交換じゃなくて
エ：今日は等価交換
エ：やっていこうと思います
エ：同じ価値じゃないと交換したらダメなんで
エ：交換してくれる方が
エ：この石と
エ：同等な価値であるモノを
エ：交換してもらいます
エ：で、その交換してもらったものを･･･
エ：その交換してもらったものを
エ：さらに別の人と
エ：同等な価値のモノと交換してもらう、と
エ：で、そのまた交換してもらったモノを
エ：別の誰かの同等な価値だと思うｎ･･･
エ：とこう･･･交換してもらう、と
エ：等価交換を続けると
エ：どこまで
エ：俺たちにとって価値の出るモノになるのか？
エ：見ていこう！
エ：弟よ！
タ：･･･そうだね、兄さん！
エ：はっはっは！
タ：アハハハ
エ：よし後は待とう･･･
タ：どっちに向けてやりますか？
エ：基本こっちかな
タ：どっち？
エ：あ"っだぁっ！！
タ：アハ･･･ｗ
タ：アハハ･･･ｗ
タ：ごめ～ん藻っ
エ：あっは～ぐっ
（茶番は終了です、もう安心してください）
エ：･･･
タ：･･･
エ：誰も来てくんねえなぁ
タ：そうだね、兄さん
エ：この
エ：賢者の石と交換しないか？
人A：賢者の石っすか？
エ：賢者の石
人A：何かを･･･
人B：何、何と交換しますか？
エ：等価交換だから
エ：もう･･･
エ：ナメとんのかあっ！！
人A：ｗｗｗ
エ：あ、お花？
エ：お花？
エ：お花が･･･
エ：お花だって
タ：お花･･･
タ：お花あり･･･
タ：あっ！
エ：あ、捨てやがった！
エ：あっ･･･ありあり！
エ：ねえこれさ、本当に？
人A：はい
エ：いやこれちょっと･･･
エ：エダワード・エルリックの･･･
エ：賢者の石だ
人A：おっす！
人A：お～っす！
エ：ああ！
人A：マァジか
エ：ありがとな！
人A：僕(動画に)出れますかこれ！？
エ：出れる！！
人A：出れる！！
エ：え、出ていいの？
人A：出ていいよ
エ：多分今、映ってるよ
人C：ホホホホｗｗ
人A：いええええええええいい！！
エ：いきなり
エ：賢者の石から
エ：iPhoneの充電器に変わりました
人A：俺もう賢者の石足りんかったら
人A：言っといたから
人A：ｗｗｗ
人B：なんかめっちゃ可愛いく見える
エ：あ、お花？
エ：あぁ～っ
人A：(そりゃ花なんだから)可愛いやろ
エ：お花かぁー･･･
人B：え、何か･･･
エ：いきなり飛躍したな
タ：いきなり飛躍した
エ：これと
エ：同等な価値のモノと･･･
エ：･･･ならば交換、するんだよ
エ：服だってよ
エ：どう思う？
タ：兄さんに任せるよ･･･
エ：交換しよう！
人D：嫌です(空耳)
人E：うおー･･･
エ：ありがとよ
エ：iPhoneのケーブルから
エ：GUの
エ：どこどこの･･･服に変わりました
エ：よし交換しよう！
人F：ありがとうございます
エ：というわけでiPhoneケースに
エ：変わってしまいました
エ：いいだろう！
エ：iPhoneケースが
エ：モバイルバッテリーに変わりました
エ：え、これマジでいいんすか？
人G：ええ、まだ･･･つｋ、あぁ･･･
人G：使わないんで
エ：交換しよう！
人G：ありがとうございます
エ：え、本当にいいの？
エ：マジでこれ？
人G：あ、いいよ･･･
エ：何か純正の
エ：ライトニングケーブルの
エ：イヤホンもらいました
エ：えーでもこれさー
エ：もうやだよーこれで終わりたいし･･･
エ：これで終わりたいしｗ
エ：是非
人H：ありがとうございます
エ：可愛くて･･･
エ：交換しちまった(キリッ
エ：ライトニングケーブルのイヤホンと
エ：おしりかじり虫を･･･のお面を
エ：交換してしまいました
エ：フッ！フッ！
エ：何かおしりかじり虫のお面と
エ：等価交換
エ：してくれる人いないか？
人I：おっしゃー！
エ：いいの？
エ：おしりかじり虫のお面と何か･･･
エ：ラッキーボックスと
エ：弓矢を
エ：くれました
エ：可愛くて交換してしまいました･･･
エ：イヤリングになってしまった･･･
人J：四つ葉のクローバー拾いました
エ：四つ葉のクローバー？
エ：四つ葉のクローバーだって
人J：めっちゃラッキーですよ
人J：今！本当に今ですよ！
エ：ありやな！
人J：やぁ～♪
人K：やった～！
人JK：あはは！
エ：レアすぎて交換してしまいました
エ：四つ葉のクローバーです
エ：なんて人だっけ？
人L：GENERATIONSの片寄涼太
エ：じぇねれーしょんの
エ：かたよせてつだってこうんがだいじ(？)
人LM：ｗｗｗｗ
エ：イエスイエスイエス
人N：アアーオッケーオッケー
エ：パーフェクト
エ：いいの？
人O：はい
エ：マジで？
エ：ダークニャンと交換してくれたー
エ：ありがとうございます
エ：へい
エ：ああお、ごめん
☚本名
エ：バナナと交換してくれました
エ：これでもスクイーズだから多分何か･･･
エ：気持ちいいやつヤッ、ですね
エ：今でしたらスクイーズのバナナだ
エ：交換する？
人P：ぬいぐるみだ
エ：いいの？
エ：それは可愛いなあ･･･
エ：やっべぇ何か･･･
エ：バナナのスクイーズから
エ：何か可愛いキューピッドのぬいぐるみに
エ：変わりました
エ：っしゃ！
エ：やったーすぎる･･･
エ：向こうも喜んでるし俺も喜んでたら
エ：何かハッピーになっちゃうね
タ：等価交換や
エ：これが錬金術の良さか
ほらぁ
エ：いらな･･･
エ：ロボット欲しい！？
タ：これ高いんだよー
エ：これはちょっと･･･
エ：あっｗ何か･･･ｗ
エ：少年
エ：これと
エ：これ
エ：どっちが欲しい？
エ：こっちか
タ：え、僕は無理だよー･･･
エ：あげよう！
エ：弟よ･･･
エ：元気でな･･･
エ：こうしてタナフォンスとの等価交換は成立し･･･
エ：俺の弟は･･･
エ：帰ってくることは無かった･･･
エ：少年･･･
エ：そして弟よ･･･
エ：･･･元気でなｗ
【ED】